Nicolas Sarkozy bonsoir nous allons
évidemment revenir sur ce coup de
théâtre à l'Assemblée j'imagine
évidemment que l'opposition se félicite
donc le PACS a été retiré il n'y aura
pas de débat en tout cas pour l'instant
vous souhaitez qu'il y ait un débat dans
l'avenir où vous souhaitez carrément que
le pack space passe aux oubliettes non
mais il faut d'abord dire que c'est très
bien pour Monsieur Jospin qui se rend
compte que la démocratie c'est une
opposition une majorité qui peut pas
faire toujours ce qu'il veut surtout
lorsque Salvat contre le bon sens
deuxièmement c'est une interrogation où
était les députés socialistes soit ils
ne viennent pas à l'Assemblée nationale
ce qui est pas bien soit il n'était pas
d'accord sur le texte qu'ils avaient
eux-mêmes présenté dans ce cas là ils
ont menti à ceux qui prétendaient
défendent et représenter on va pas
préjugés
maintenant le gouvernement s'est pris
les pieds dans le tapis c'était un
monstre juridique nous ce que nous avons
voulu faire c'est l'idée que l'on se
fait de la famille depuis des années des
années nous ne voulons pas que nous
touche alors qu'est-ce qu'on non je vais
vous donner tout de suite la parole mais
avant d'aller au fond parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un problème de fond on
pourra d'ailleurs pas faire le débat
complètement ce soir vous avez gagné là
sur une bataille de procédure vous
imaginez bien que pour les citoyens ça
n'est pas satisfaisant madame
excusez-moi de quelle citoyen
parlez-vous vous pensez vous pensez que
tous les citoyens étaient étaient pour
le pacte pas du tout mais je pense que
le débat méritait d'être là ou peut-être
faut-il qu'il dépasse la question le
débat nous l'avons mené la question
préalable a été défendue d'excellente
manière
qu'est-ce qu'elle est le problème
aujourd'hui et je veux notamment
m'adresser puisque j'ai vu dans les
différents reportages un certain nombre
de réactions de la communauté
homosexuelle il y a des problèmes qui se
posent aux homosexuels personne ne le
conteste personne n'est surtout pas nous
ne voulons nous attaquer à leur liberté
nous disons simplement une chose simple
et j'espère compréhensible par tous ceux
qui nous regardent on peut résoudre les
problèmes des homosexuels au regard de
la donation au regard des successions
dans un couple homosexuel en touchant
aux mesures fiscales ce que nous ne
voulons pas c'est que nos touches à la
famille à notre code de la famille et
que l'on crée un vrai faux sous mariage
si le gouvernement nous dit il s'agit de
résoudre les problèmes des homosexuels
par le biais de la fiscalité nous
discuterons bien volontiers s'il veut
porter atteinte à la famille mais quel
sera le mariage le 24 octobre prochain
où il y aura des balles assemblées je
crains que Monsieur j'ose pas ne
connaissent pas la procédure
parlementaire car le 24 octobre c'est
pas la date pour les socialistes car
soit le texte est représenté sous forme
de proposition de loi et la prochaine
niche parlementaire pour les socialistes
c'est en février soit le texte est
présenté sous forme de projet de loi
l'initiative du gouvernement et dans ce
cas là il doit passer devant le Conseil
d'État il doit passer devant la clim
parce que le gouvernement voulait
fichier les homosexuels il doit passer
en commission et il doit revenir à
l'Assemblée nationale il suffit pas de
Dunkerque monsieur Jospin qui sait tout
sur tout disent ça sera dans 15 jours
donc il suffit
pas nous sommes d'accord mais il y a une
procédure parle savez-vous dans une
démocratie il y a des votes qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée une
majorité de leur présentation nationale
a dit non à ce texte donc on reviendra
pour discuter de ce texte dans d'autres
conditions qui respecteront les règles
de la démocratie si je vous comprends
bien je vais essayer de vous résumer au
réformes fiscales mais pas non tellement
de la famille il n'y aura pas de débat
le 24 octobre je voudrais on voudrait
nous faire dire qu'en deux semaines il
faut tout changer recommencer pourquoi
parce que les socialistes ont été battus
c'est ça qui est gênant alors une
deuxième question tout aussi simple
est-ce que vous pensez que ce projet
devrait être proposition de loi devrait
devenir un projet de loi et que le
gouvernement prenne l'initiative de ce
débat qui au fond est un vrai débat de
société non madame c'est un faux débat
de société on veut faire croire à la
communauté homosexuelle qu'on résoudra
leurs problèmes en créant un faux
mariage un sous mariage nous disons
qu'il suffit tiens dans le cadre de la
discussion budgétaire que le
gouvernement dépose des amendements
fiscaux pour résoudre les problèmes de
donation et de succession
entre deux personnes homosexuelles et à
ce moment-là il n'y a plus de problèmes
madame mais si on veut pas toucher à la
famille alors on fait comme ça si on
veut toucher à la famille on trouvera
l'opposition unie déterminée et très
compatible on a compris le PACS ne
concerne pas exclusivement les
homosexuels moi j'ai pris quelques
chiffres 2 millions de personnes qui
vivent en concubinage un million de
couples et non mariés avec enfants 39%
de des naissances qui sont en mariage
aujourd'hui c'est donc un débat qui
concerne
n'est pas du tout pas du tout qui
contexte qu'on a le droit de vivre en
concubinage qui est contre savez-vous
madame qu'un enfant qui va naître dans
le cadre du PACS est-ce que vous le
savez qu'il n'aura pas la présomption de
paternité et ce que vous savez qu'une
femme unie dans le cadre du PACS n'aura
le droit ni à prestation compensatoire
ni à pension alimentaire en cas de
rupture de ce PACS est-ce que c'est ça
qu'on veut est-ce que c'est ça les
grands débats de société de fragiliser
la femme et l'enfant donc vous savez
c'est un débat trop important pour
consentir à quelques slogans alors
venons-en parce que évidemment on a
beaucoup de choses à voir ensemble
faudrait pas que c'était un débat en
lui-même venant en maintenant aux
mesures concernant l'insécurité dans les
transports l'opposition à immédiatement
réagi elle a multiplié peut-être les
réticences ou les critiques face à ce
que pouvait annoncer monsieur Joslin
hier en tout cas il y a au moins une
chose sur laquelle vous pouvez être
d'accord c'est peut-être lorsque
Monsieur Jospin oppose l'ordre à
l'insécurité là ça peut que vous
satisfaire non mais madame je suis très
satisfait que Monsieur Jospin dise la
même chose qu'il avait dit il y a un an
à Villepinte mais est-ce que vous croyez
vraiment que les usagers des transports
en commun peuvent se satisfaire de ces
discours ou à juste deux ou trois
remarques c'est un défaut bien
socialiste que de croire qu'on résout
les problèmes en modifiant la loi en
augmentant les règlements c'est pas en
faisant de nouvelles lois de nouvelles
cathédrale juridique qu'on va recréer
les conditions de sécurité dans les
transports en commun la loi existe elle
doit être appliquée la deuxième remarque
pourquoi il y a ces phénomènes de
délinquance extrêmement préoccupants
parce que il y a un sentiment d'impunité
chez ceux qui commettent ces actes qui
devient intolérable pour les usages de
ces transports en communauté monsieur
Jospin on a parlé l'impunité il n'y en
aura pas il la précisé on va pas revenir
en détail sur les mesures on n'a pas le
temps ce que je pourrais dire
excusez-moi monsieur Jospin est venu
s'expliquer 50 minutes c'est normal les
premiers ministres je ne le conteste pas
j'aurais juste terminer là-dessus on a
beaucoup parlé de la prévention ces
dernières années je pense qu'on a oublié
de dire que la sanction et le premier
élément de la prévention et j'ajoute une
grande absence dans le discours du
premier ministre c'est l'affaire si
préoccupante de la multiplication des
délits commis par des mineurs il va bien
falloir d'une manière ou d'une autre
responsabiliser financièrement les
parents de mineurs qui commettent des
dégâts il va bien falloir d'une manière
ou d'une autre se résoudre à poser le
problème de l'éloignement de leur milieu
et de leur quartier d'origine pour les
mineurs multi récidivistes il va falloir
poser la question des allocations
familiales qu'on en discute calmement
tranquillement il va falloir répondre à
l'interrogation des US doublement
victime victime parce qu'ils ont peur et
victimes parce qu'il n'y a pas un
service minimum les jours de grève ce
sont des sujets qui méritent mieux que
des discours qui se suivent qui se
ressemblent et qui n'apporte pas de
réponse je voyais que on demandait aux
agents de la RATP maintenant de faire
les contrôles d'identité alors vous
voyez l'agent qui contrôle les billets
qui a déjà tant de mal à contrôler le
billet je pense à ce programme qui a un
travail bien difficile les bus qui vont
maintenant dans les quartiers ou la
police n'osent pas aller mais on est
au-delà du problème politique vous savez
bien que la délinquance touchait à la
fois les États-Unis la Grande-Bretagne
vous parlez de la délinquance des
mineurs vous pensez que c'est pas un
problème bouche droite c'est un problème
de société et cette politique là aussi
vous l'avez faite et vous en êtes
responsable vous comme d'autres c'est
l'échec d'une société madame d'abord
quand on l'ont dit c'est pas un problème
gauche-droite c'est une formule dans une
démocratie et l'opposition et une
majorité ne me reprochez pas ou qu'on me
reproche pas d'être de droite vous me
dites d'autres pays le connaissent
justement les États-Unis sont résolu
notamment à New York qui a eu des
reportages y compris dans votre journal
l'Angleterre est en train de s'attaquer
à ce problème avec beaucoup de fermeté
la question finalement est assez simple
on peut pas mettre un policier derrière
chaque conducteur d'autobus et on ne
peut pas demander un conducteur
d'autobus dont le rôle c'est de conduire
un bus d'aller dans des zones de
non-droit est-ce que oui ou non on est
décidé à faire appliquer la loi avec ses
vérités parce que ce sentiment
d'impunité aujourd'hui n'est plus
acceptable par la population c'est cela
dont il s'agit nécessaire
venons-en maintenant à ce